you're old news I have no idea what that
reference yes even I'm too shy to talk
about that and it's not amusing at all
[Music]
hi I'm Monica and I'm here with my dog
Judd Apatow and we're here to take a
test to see how well we know it so this
is your nightmare let's begin okay the
first question is what is your exact
birthday dad your birthday is December 6
1967 that's good and your birthday is
December 15 1997 that is not amusing at
all their astrological sign and we have
the same one Sagittarius it's the best
one yeah what is Sagittarius mean like
what qualities do we have I have never
really been into astrology so I don't
know but I think stubbornness or what
their middle name you don't have a
middle name but then when you and mom
got married she made you sneakily change
your middle name too man right I think
I'm now jug man and your middle name is
Annabelle and you don't love it you
don't love it
not a favorite part of your being their
shoe size you're an 11 or an 11 and a
half and you are a woman's woman's nine
that's that correct yes I know it's
something we talk about a lot because
you're not you're not pleased with the
size of your dog's cheese their height
you're 511 because you're not fixed yeah
I went in the doctor and the last time
they would tell me was five ten and a
half I think a lot to happen in you
gotta get into Pilates table and stretch
it out a little bit and you are we have
a wall with everyone's height and
markers but I'm gonna say five five yeah
that's right all I know is you're
shorter than iris and enraged about
that's really oh the name of their first
boyfriend or girlfriend
I fully know yours wait and you gave her
like a top I her still in seventh grade
I can't remember her name I gave her a
silkscreen of a tiger that I bought at
the mall for $40 seventh grade Jill her
name is Jill oh shoot I I don't know who
we even define as your first boyfriend
there were a couple that kind of drifted
through for a day or two I don't know if
those are considered boyfriends and you
know what let's let's say their name
it'll deserve it I don't want to give
anyone that title you're old news
biggest pet peeve Wow that's a good one
what is my pet peeve I feel like half
that peeps like that I won't be people
telling me not to eat something but is
that even a pet peeve I don't know but
stop it what's mine I've so many babies
your pet peeve is people with dirty
hands touching your food that's true or
your face or just Phil you don't like to
kill yeah that's true that's a fight
that my sister and I get into when she
like reach her fingers into my food to
like have a bite but it's her fingers
fingers touch things yeah Oh their
favorite TV show do you have one
specific one yeah maybe the wire or NYPD
blue your favorite TV show a long time
is clearly without hesitation RuPaul's
Drag Race reality show of all time and
then your favorite show of all time
Breaking Bad I don't know if you got
that one oh man it's lost
it's tricky I feel like it's definitely
between like lost The Sopranos or
broadchurch
I don't know I don't know I love
broadchurch but you're putting
broadchurch sexes and Sopranos this
madness I'm changing my vote to Sopranos
number two euphoria
I'm switching to your show your favorite
Judd Apatow movie and I know what it
isn't which is funny people which you've
never seen and you refuse to see for
reasons which don't really make sense
other than
yes you know I find it annoying that you
will never watch it why won't you watch
it it's just become so much of a thing
by running joke in the family your
refusal to ever watch funny people is
just as a bug thing and you're in it am
I supposed to say your favorite movie of
your own movies those movies I've been
involved in in some way I feel like your
favorite movie of your own movies is
walk lark or funny people that's a good
question I don't know but I'll tell you
the one minute makes me laugh the most
the movie that will Ferrell and Adam
McKay made that I was a producer on
stepbrothers you gotta keep going back
to step brothers they're brothers making
make sure oh I can guess what yours
would be and everything of you liking
anything I'm a part of or you're a part
of let's just say frightening I was
gonna say Step Brothers okay we're in
agreement okay your favorite actor I
don't know if I know I don't know I know
I don't know if I never thought like my
favorite actor is but let me tell you
something what pops into my mind first
two seasons of NYPD Blue David Caruso
NYPD I have no idea what that reference
yes like a specific person mind either
Edie Falco she's great let's just say
Ivanka we're gonna stick with The
Sopranos thing okay Leslie man she's on
the side it's family that's cheating
Edie Falco celebrity crush I don't think
you would've already crushed that's too
weird to do and your celebrity crush
Benedict under No David Tennant from
broadchurch as you mentioned broadchurch
Michael and parolee from Sopranos I'm
just trying to did you I know it used to
be Zac Efron I know back in the day I
don't know if you transitioned not as -
while you were go to alcoholic beverage
send us a free case for saying it white
cloth that's true I mean you don't
really drink alcohol but maybe like my
tie
chicklet well nighttime and daddy takes
a nap your favorite band that's easy the
tea that's that's pretty true okay
wait away today do not like think about
it hmm I know it's so obvious Pearl Jam
or or welcome oh who oh and the who
their allergies I don't know what your
specific allergies are but you always
have allergies I feel like you over like
life allergies that are connected to
your stress I have emotional allergies
and I also went to a doctor once and
they said I was allergic to air
pollution in the air you have a gluten
allergy that's true
nickname you have a nickname we don't
really have in their conveyance to other
people have nickname for me like when I
was young what am i friends my component
oh you tell I feel like my name is not a
very nickname type of name Modelo
that's what my grandma come as close as
we get that is our test I got 14 and
Maude got 12 dad wins I feel like it
would be weird if you if you lost it
would show bad parenting I didn't know
you at all it would be so creepy
oh for 20
[Music]
you